LOST 9 OF THEIR LAST 10 GAMES
CORNER.
JASON DICKINSON IST IS CONOR GA.
GAMES IN PITTSBURGH THE OTHER
NIGHT.
SCRATCH AND CLAW OUT OF IT.
WE HEARD KEVIN BIEKSA TALKING
ABN THE LAST 4 GAMES AND
3-26 OF THE LAST 10.
HORVAT.
IT DOESN'T WORK OUT.
VANCOUVER LINE. AMN HIS 600th G.
>> Garry: BETTER TO TAKE IT IN
OFFSIDE AND TAKE THE
IN THE NET TO BE CRERE GO OFF H
SKSK
ALL OF A SUDDEN IT'S TO THE NET
ADVICE AS WELL, GARRY.
RUN YOUR OWN RACE.
>> Garry: TOO
BURROUGHS.
BROKEN UP ALONG THE BOARDS.
DVORAK HAS IT IN TIGHT.
TOFFOLI LEAVES IT FOR
CROWD WANTED A CALL.
ANDERSON WILL TAKE OFF THEFOOTI.
THE CROWD WAS GETTING UPSET
ABOUT IT.
PEARSON ISMES IN MONTREAL AGAIN
ALLEN MAKES THE SAVE, FEBRUARY
24th UP.
IT'S CLEARED OFF TO CENTRE.
HUGHES IS THERE.
>> John: CAUFIELD JUMPS ON THE
LOOSE PUCK.
>> Garry: WELL AN
SUZUKI RAN INTO HIS OWN MAN.D L.
YOU KNOW, ON THE PENALTY
MONTREAL CANADIENS WHO ARE GOING
TO GET A TWO-GAME WINNING STREAK
GOING OR THE
GOT IT IN TIGHT FOR TOFFOLI.
KNOCKS
BACK FOR SUZUKI.
TO THE LINE. ON THE SHORT
SIDE AND THEN THE PUCK DOESN'T
GET OUT.
AND THEN FRO
JAKE EVANS LONE MAN IN THEREUP,.
HERE'S DICKINSON.
HE WILL LIFT IT OUT. OF THE GOA.
BEN CHIAROT TRYING TO SHAKE OFF.
ALLEN HAS GOT  G TO HOLD HIM
OFF.
HERE COMES GALLAGHER.